i'm beth kimberly i'm an author and
taste expert today i'm answering your
questions from twitter
welcome to taste support
[Music]
first up all out of coffee asks can
someone please explain to me the
difference between tart and sour tastes
here's something for you they're the
same but in the professional tasting
industry we use the term sour but we
don't just use sour we use the terms
lactic sour basic sour or acetic sour
acetic sour is the type of sour that
you're getting from things like vinegar
lactic sour is the type of sour that
you're getting from things like
buttermilk or yogurt and basic sour
that is the sour of citric acid or
something citrus on your mouth this is
from eileen terrell and she's asking
could someone please explain to me the
science of why blue raspberry is by far
the best fruit flavor even though blue
raspberry isn't even real so in the food
industry a flavor house is where product
developers and food scientists go to
source flavors sometimes they go to a
flavor house and say hey i want an
orange but i it to be more of a mandarin
orange and it needs to be cooked and i'd
like at this level of sweet and this
level of sour sometimes the flavor house
has a library of flavors that you can
choose from so blue raspberry might have
been one of those wacky flavors that the
flavor house developed or came from the
mind of a scientist if you try blue
raspberry i'm not sure about this but i
almost wonder if somebody took raspberry
and combine it with grape all right so
we have a question from beyonce does
anyone have remedies for bringing taste
and smell back to a hundred percent
after covid
crying face it's been almost a year and
i'm still suffering one of the things
that you can do is practice you can get
yourself some essential oils in a range
of different flavors and what you're
going to do
is just pass them under your nose just
take little bunny sniffs not
too much and then you're going to tell
yourself
okay that's lemongrass what's going to
happen is slowly but surely you're going
to trigger your memory and your brain to
sort of remember what that was here's
the thing it will come back a lot of
people have had sort of phantom smells
or weird smells as a result of of covid
but we're now seeing that that in time
goes away and you can train yourself to
come back a little bit faster all right
we've got a question from roshibi i ate
so much sour candy that my tongue is raw
and it hurts now i love sour candy so
much why did it have to betray me like
this i feel your pain but on the outside
of sour candy is something called citric
acid and it's those little crystals when
you have something sour that get into
your
literally papillae your tongue right it
can eat away at the roof of your mouth
it can eat away your tongue so whatever
sour candy you're eating it might be a
little extreme all right next question
and this is from super 70s sports i
don't know what shackleberry finn is but
one thing i know it is definitely not a
[ __ ] flavor and super 70s sports is
also including a picture of oh my gosh
it's like a classic kool-aid pack with
the pitcher guy writing a shark at the
top it says charcoal berry finn it also
says it's pink okay so we're getting
some clues here what flavor would this
be it is not a flavor but this is a way
for food companies to own a flavor
because i see charcoal berry fin tm and
it looks like this was produced i don't
know in the 80s or something and so they
probably didn't get the memo that shark
fin is illegal number one number two i
think you do want to cue your customers
into what flavor this is but it's got
this wild like devil may care packaging
i think it's like come into this crazy
shark world with us it is not a flavor
but it is a way for a food company to
kind of own a concept right because the
three top flavors chocolate vanilla and
strawberry are kind of out there already
i don't know what sharkleberry finn is
but one thing i know it's definitely not
a flavor this is from doing it to them
this is great i want chicken nuggets so
bad ops is all in caps so bad dude why
is mcdonald's so good but also so
terrible why are they so addicting
they're so addicting because they have
been formulated in a lab this is chicken
that's been combined with potato and
other ingredients so it can be formed
and molded and then
breaded and fried what the
lab has done is to try to modulate the
taste so that it's just the right
perfect amount of sweet and salty and
sour and bitter and umami right so those
are the five basic tastes when you can
combine them in just the right way foods
are addicting like they
can nail it and that's why chicken
nuggets oh my gosh just the smell makes
people cave and they go for them we have
a question from gripe gal explain to me
how with all the science in the world
the taste of gum only lasts five minutes
yet the taste of onion lasts 864 hours
this gum has a coloring system a
flavoring system and what's called
gum base and what happens when you
masticate or chew product is that you're
moving through the sweetener system and
it's basically going into your stomach
right so as you move through this it
tastes great some of the sweetening
systems will use artificial flavor which
actually increase over time and allow
you to enjoy gum for a little bit longer
the other thing about gum and flavor
some flavors are stronger than others
right so if you have gums that have
peppermints or mints in them those are
longer lasting more robust flavors now
onto
onions why does that flavor lasts so
long and linger onions
garlic they contain sulfur and those
flavors as opposed to just dissolving
and going into your stomach those
flavors actually get in your bloodstream
and so if you've ever had a large dose
of garlic and then smelled your skin the
next day you're exuding that
garlic flavor when you're chewing gum
the flavors are dissolving and simply
put they're not going anywhere else but
they're but your stomach they're
breaking down whereas for onions and
garlic those flavors are staying in your
system perhaps for days depending on how
much you ate all right now we have a
question from
bkru zavon how does the tongue know
different tastes
people
your tongue has about give or take 10
000 teaspoons taste buds
take in
information using these receptors that's
then signaling your brain what you're
about to taste
and that simple step is really important
so that people don't start ingesting
things that are bad for them back in the
day scientists thought that your tongue
was divided into sections and that you'd
actually have to taste sweet at the
front or sour on the sides but we now
know that we have these taste receptors
and they're spread evenly throughout the
tongue so that you're able to taste all
five basic taste throughout the tongue
next up from zero six honda crv who is
the person that created the flavor of
flaming hot cheetos and where can i meet
and talk to them guess what it's not a
person it's like a whole team of people
who create flavors so it's a marketing
team it's a science team it's a product
development team and that flavoring
could have taken them years to make and
guess what they're not going to talk to
you because flavors are sort of the
secret identity of foods right there's a
reason the recipe for coca-cola is
locked up in a safe so
you might meet one of them but they've
all signed nda's and they're not telling
you anything all right so now we have
another question from now theo and now
theo asks a really important question
what's a super taster
the typical tongue has about 10 000
taste buds on it and anything over that
means you're a super taster right so
you've got these extra taste buds that
means you're taking in way more
information about food so for instance
if i taste kale right like a really
bitter kale that bitter might be we use
scales in sensory evaluation so for
intensity scales we use from 1 to 15.
let's say that kale is at you know a 10
or 11 for me for a super taster that
bitter because they have more receptors
might taste like a 15 all the way at the
end of the scale so bitter that like
their gag reflexes kick in so there's
actually a way to test if you're a super
taster at home you just need a few
things
some food dye
a q-tip and a piece of paper with a
standard hole punch in it we're gonna
bring in brandon who's a producer on the
set to see if he's a super taster more
than 35 happily means that brandon's a
super taster i have this q-tip i'm just
going to put a little bit of dye on it
i'm going to go right in there the next
step is going to be to count exactly how
many papillae brandon has on his tongue
uh-huh oh great shot and now i'm going
to count them to see if he's a super
taster
there's exactly 35 which is what a
typical taster would have so brandon's
in the normal range not quite a super
taster but maybe that's for the best
next question from
danny guerrero fruity pebbles are all
the same flavor
yet each one tastes different what is
the science name for this situation
placebo effect
uh
good guess but it's actually not the
fruity pebbles are all the same flavor
it's probably a combination of fruit so
it could be cherry strawberry grape
let's say but the colors are different
your mind interprets those or takes that
information in as those being
different are really in different
flavors a really interesting test was
done with wine experts and they gave
wine experts white wine colored with red
dye and these experts every single one
of them thought that white wine was red
wine because of the red dye and the
interesting thing is we eat with our
eyes and so we get fooled all the time
even professional tasters fooling
consumers is something that consumer
packaged goods companies have have been
doing for a long time it's a way of
saving costs there's a reason fruity
pebbles don't have individual flavors
the other thing is that flavor does
something really interesting it's called
migration so if you had an orange one
and a green one eventually over time
they'd start tasting all the same all
right so eric sherry asks how do pop
rocks work there's gas in those little
pieces of candy that is activated when
moisture hits them the one thing that
makes pop rocks really interesting is
that it's also textural you're actually
hearing those popping and you're taking
in a lot of sensory information with a
pop rock so it's not just about the
flavor it's like something's happening
they're really a cool product in that
you're really using all your senses when
you're experiencing a pop rock and next
up snot asks why does sprite from
mcdonald's taste different than a sprite
in bottle so the sprite you're getting
from mcdonald's is flavoring and bubbly
water that have come together likely out
of a machine
or a gun
and sprite that's in a bottle comes from
a manufacturing plant and has sort of a
different profile packaging whether it's
a bottle a cardboard box or a film
wrapper oftentimes have flavors
associated with them where do those you
know flavors and or aromas come from
they can come from the inks they can
come from the plastics so one of the
sort of misunderstood things is that
sprite that comes out of a gun would
taste like sprite in a bottle the
ingredients in the actual sprite drink
might be the same but the sprite bottle
could have some flavors that come from
the actual packaging all right so we
have a question from itsy girl skype
alexa this is in all caps how are
different flavors of cheese created that
is an interesting question and i am not
a cheese maker but i will tell you that
cheese starts with milk they add enzymes
that change both the sugars in the
cheese and the proteins and over time
those tastes can go in a lot of
different directions depending on the
type of milk the type of enzymes so
cheese is incredibly complex i mean i
chased it a cheese with a client the
other day and it had butter notes it had
citrus notes it had
umami it had all different notes in it
and it's all dependent on how long you
let it store what type of enzymes and
what type of dairy you use this is from
max attacks
why do they put colors to taste
especially when they make pink
starbursts taste like strawberries
effing liars strawberries aren't pink
here's why they put colors to taste our
brain is also taking in visual signals
or visual cues from food so they put
colors to taste to give us the cue that
something is sweet or has a has a flavor
if you look at a strawberry starburst
it's not like red red like a strawberry
it's still kind of you know it's still
pinkish and the reason is they can't
load the amount of red that you know
would be required or would match a
strawberry in that that candy that would
be a lot of color there's also
a legacy around red
food dye
certain food colorings are have been
tied to you know illnesses back in the
day they took the red m m out of the m m
pack because there was legal
implications around using red dye we
have a question from men adams 95 i'm
confused what is the flavor of coca-cola
and this is an incredible question
because oftentimes we don't really think
of all the nuanced flavors in coca-cola
so what's in coca-cola well it starts
with the cola not right that's sort of
the base flavor but then you can have a
lot of brown spice most of us in the
flavor
community think there's a little
sarsaparilla in there sarsaparilla is
the base for root beer and then there's
also this stick with me
fruit flavor when you know how to taste
you can really take coca-cola and
analyze it and break out all of the
flavors it's not just sweet it's not
just cola it's a little spicy it's a
little minty and it's a little fruity so
if you've ever had a coke and a pepsi
and tasted them well the tastes are
different so the spice levels might be a
little bit different but one thing's for
sure the sweet level is vastly different
guess which one's sweeter pepsi we have
a question from i'm the critic how does
one even explain the feeling slash taste
of wasabi it's not really spicy or sour
it just burns your nose okay this is
actually a really interesting one
because the flavor of wasabi and the
spice when you're a professional taster
you can piece those apart so the flavor
of wasabi it's in the mustard family by
the way a lot of people like into
horseradish on steroids right because
it's spicier than just a regular
horseradish so a lot of people can
explain it by saying it tastes like
horseradish with an increased intensity
so if horseradish is at a five wasabi
might be out of 15 but it also has the
taste of a root vegetable and is in the
mustard family
finally we have a question from arg i'm
a pirate how do i become a ben and
jerry's flavor guru okay great question
it sounds like maybe you already have
some practice in becoming one a lot of
people come in to the world of flavor
with a science background so that's an
option you can go in that direction or
you can get yourself a bunch of pints
take it slow do what we call meditative
eating and
do a taste test right start really
tasting what's what's in there and if
you can start mapping the taste in in
ben and jerry's i don't know maybe you
can get hired as a as a guru a lot of
food companies
need consumer tasters so you can sign up
for a consumer taste test with ben
jerry's or an ice cream company to be a
taster
check that out okay that's it we're done
with all the questions i really hope you
guys learned something and had some fun
and until next time
[Music]